maybe
maybe there's something else for levon
ironian i'm not sure but either way
you'll move your wanker blocking this
e-line blocking the white rook's root in
towards the black king and then he does
it
he does it yeah look at those two black
rooks they're the ideal shield it's
literally look they look like a shield
right now the black king holding them in
front and magnus carlsen resigns i'm
rooking a piece down he just gives up ah
minus uh what do you think david just a
little bit tired today yeah maybe tired
and also we can't blame him he's won the
tour finals and it's always difficult to
refocus once you've achieved such a big
goal like that
well we're gonna head out to the lounge
and hear from the world champion
okay so a tough day for you
how do you feel after this oh it's okay
it's just okay
yeah i mean i don't love it but
you know
it's the way it is
okay that's amazing how do you feel the
games went today
um
i didn't feel like i should lost the
first one i felt like
i was um
i was doing okay and then
then i kind of lost control after that
uh and then yeah the rest of the day was
pretty poor
magnus carlsen winning winner of the
tournament and quite okay with uh with
the result
yeah i know i mean obviously i should
play better than i have the last few
days but
so it is
it is what is